mein name ist dr wie kann ich war im
jahr 2010 als ziviler arzt im
auslandseinsatz und da wo ich das so
genannte bergdoktor
ich habe ganz normal eine kleine truppe
märz koordination geführt mit einer
relativ großen apotheke mit einem
notfallrucksack überhaupt oben insgesamt
vier positions zu betreuen gehabt die
ich je nach notfall im ghetto mit ski
oder mitte juli
also mit einem vertrag der vor ort war
erreicht habe die erste zeit war
natürlich belastend und und einsam aber
man weiß ich zu beschäftigt man hat
lektüre mit man hat lernen damit man hat
ein laptop mit es gibt da internet auch
und die kameradschaft ist es hoch
geschrieben wird und das weiß ich sehr
zu schätzen ich arbeite noch kontakt
über soziale medien mit kamera mit einer
nie dort drei monate meines lebens
verbringen dürfen
und du kannst wirklich nur empfehlen
auslandseinsatz mit bundesheer zu machen
wegen der erfahrung gesammelt und er
seine eindrücke erlebnisse sonst sicher
nicht